بالتدريب والسلاح المقدم من الغرب تستعد
اوكرانيا لشن هجومها المضاد الذي طال
انتظاره بحسب تقرير لواشنطن بوست
الامريكيه الصحيفه اشارت الى ان الوحدات
التي دربتها وسلحتها دول نيتو ستكون
بمثابه راس الحربه في الهجوم الاوكراني
والقت الضوء على اللواء الميكانيكي السابع
والاربعين الذي تدرب لاشهر في عده دول على
التكتيكات الحربيه الاكثر تقدما بعد
انتهاء المناورات التي قام بها اللواء
الميكانيكي اذ تم تجهيزه باسلحه غربيه بما
في ذلك مركبات برادلي القتاليه
ونقلت الوحده الى موقع سري اقرب الى خط
الجبهه ورات الصحيفه ان الهجوم المضاد
سيكون اوضح اختبار للاستراتيجيه التي
تقودها الولايات المتحده لمنح الاوكرانيين
الاسلحه والتدريب للقتال بشكل مماثل للجيش
الامريكي بعدما تم تدريب عشرات الاف
الجنود في عدد من دول الناتو بريطانيا على
سبيل المثال اعلنت اكمال تدريب عشره الاف
مجند اوكراني على اراضيها منذ بدء الحرب
مع اعتزامها تدريب اربعين الفا اخرين خلال
العام الجاري والكثير منهم تدربوا على
دبابات تشالنجر 2 التي تم تسليمها لكياف
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه في جانب اخر قامت
اسبانيا بدعم الاف الجنود الاوكرانيين
بالتدريب على مختلف الاسلحه بما فيها
دبابات ليوبارد في اكاديميه توليدو للمشاه
واذا انتقلنا الى المانيا التي دربت
الجنود بالفعل على الدبابات ذاتها
كما انها اعلنت منتصف الشهر الماضي وصول
دبابات ابرمز الامريكيه الى المانيا
لتدريب اطقم الدبابات الاوكرانيه اخيرا
الى بولندا التي قامت بدور كبير في تدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين على مختلف الاسلحه
والتكتيكات الى ان اعلنت قبل ايام عن
بدئها في تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
قياده مقاتلات اف 16 بعد ضوء اخضر امريكي
لهذه الخطوه ومع التدريبات المكثفه للقوات
الاوكرانيه الا ان دعم الغربي يبقى مشروطا
بعدم استخدام هذه الاسلحه في مهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات